This is the first film where I worked with
professional actors
so that was really different and
interesting, and I think, for example...
There's a scene where she is kind of
trying to seduce
this former, personal trainer. She has some
difficulty and there's this moment
where she kind of goes
nuts on him.
It's a difficult scene
to play, and if you have a whole cast
and crew around you, and it's late at night
and with the lights are on and the
camera's rolling
..it's a lot of pressure and I think takes a
particular kind of person to step up at
that moment and
you know, she was great.
If you're writing a film project for a non-actor
either you're gonna need like a lot of time to be able to work with the person to get them to that point
or you need a lot of film, but it's certainly
not something that seems easy to me.